what's going on tazan what's up buddy
how are you my
friend you know what I think it's
something about you I was like these
Edibles might have been not good but
then they just started kicking in like
literally as soon as your face popped up
I was like that's right that's right I'm
like that dude from [__] Star
Trek which one I don't know the ugly
one What's happen you Savages it's
Tuesday the 21st of November the checkin
is BR brought to you by one of my
favorites freeze pipe listen freeze pipe
wants you to smoke and save bigness
holiday season they're running their
biggest sale event of the year now
through the end of November but they got
some tremendous deals for Black Friday
perfect for medical patients who want a
c free experience or anyone who's Tred
who's tired of harsh smoke and coughing
and [__] spitting the secret is a
freezable glycerin Chambers just pop the
chamber in the freezer for one hour as
the smoke passes through it chills your
throat you don't have no after bur no
coughin no nothing it's tremendous they
got listen the freeze pipe got whatever
pipe you need from small to large to
[__] Magnum bomb so try your uncle
Joey's favorite way to light up by
visiting thefree pipe.com again thefree
pipe.com
and enter code Diaz Diaz for 10% off
your entire order that's right shop
massive black Friday Cyber Monday sales
running now until the end of November or
use code Diaz for 10% off only at the
free pipe.com uh oh the checkin is also
brought to you by ho ho ho scumbags
Uncle Joey's here to put smooth balls on
your Christmas list manscapes new
performance 5.0 Ultra has everything you
need to make your [__] Tree of Love
look awesome it comes with the lawn mow
Ultra body trimmer and the weed whacker
2.0 and an ear and nose hair trimmer
that crop Soother After Shave lotion
which is like putting ice ice cubes on
your nut sack and the crop preserver
ball deodorant this package is [__]
tremendous they sent to me about two
weeks ago I [__] trimmed her I had
nothing to do last week I was horizontal
so you might as well trim your pole the
lawm more 5.0 Ultra does it all it comes
with two blade heads and it's waterproof
and it's even got a light all right the
performance package is everything you
need so you can shape up look feel and
your balls smell oof P get 20% off in
free shipping with code Joey at
manscape.com
again that's 20% off and free shipping
at
manscape.com use code Joey now if you
don't mind let's get this [__] party
started turn off your TVs run for your
lives it's over they didn't put you on
this planet just to give up if Uncle
Joey could do it I could rule the world
that's what you got to be thinking
welcome back
[Music]
to
what up moo what up buddy I'm doing good
I'm I'm really happy to see you I I bet
you are cuck sucking yeah I'm Happ
what's up buddy everything good over
there everything's really good man I had
a good week I didn't really it was a
slow week but it was I tried to I tried
to take I didn't try to I took some some
muss and nothing happened I've never had
that happen before you're [__]
tolerance you're blowing up like you
thought I would call the [__] same
number same Hood it's all good well it
was they were very nice but like Tuesday
what Tuesday What's tomorrow what's
today's date the 21st are you [__]
kidding me November the 21st are you
[__] kidding me and I did call the
guy kidnapped on Saturday on the
anniversary but he didn't answer he
didn't return answer nah he moved to
Kent Bella moved to [__] New Mexico
he left Arizona he was in
Tucson and then he went to New Mexico
after his mother passed I was gonna say
he lived with his mom for a bit right he
was living with his mom since I
kidnapped him what are you talking about
he's been down in Arizona for like 20
[__]
years and when did he stop answering
your call no he always we always talk
before before he went to New Mexico we
had a long conversation about moving and
uh you know but he had to switch jobs I
think he sells like solar panels or
something to do with that he had to
switch
offices so yeah we just spoke about
generalities but I always call him on
the anniversary you know just because
I'm that type of [__] you know
Hallmark hasn't made a happy kidnapping
anniversary card yet you know
so I got a send I reach out to him and I
talk to him but he didn't call me back I
left a message for him told him I was
thinking about loved him you know do you
guys joke about it do you say you're
sorry what do you say every once in a
while he'll make a [__] remark you
know when you come to New York you have
to go for the restaurant he'll go last
time I went somewhere with you I ended
up handcuffed you know he always makes
little Sly [__] remarks yeah you're
not gonna let that go
he had a rough day that day so I I you
know that's okay how do you like do how
do you feel about it as it comes up to
the date do you like start dreading it
or does it like pop up on you no it pops
up on me it'll pop up on me like
November 16th and then I go November 16
oh [__] on the 18th as the anniversary
of
ell [__] you know so it is what it is it
was a long time ago 30 [__] six years
ago guy nobody remembers and guess what
nobody gives a [__] either
so I give a [__] because I did it so
I've always tried to make peace with
this [__]
lunatic and now we're good we're really
good I'm really happy how that's going
you know I [__] up I apologize and uh
it's funny I saw somebody the other day
who I need to apologize to somebody who
I was with
ever since I moved here and then things
got a little weird one night and I said
something and she said something so I
saw her the other day and I go I gotta
apologize to her I love apologizing to
people you know do apologize yeah you
got to apologize to people they deserve
that some people like [__] you some
people like I get it I get where you're
coming from you know so you know I'm the
type of guy when I got to drop an
apology I I think about it for a few
days I mean listen nobody ever wants to
apologize right it's one of the toughest
things you'll ever do and I [__]
hated it as a kid and as I got older I'm
like you know it's one of those things
that people deserve it whether they
believe it or not they'll be mad at you
for a month and they go you know at
least the dude tried he apologized he
sent flowers he he sent my kid a [__]
flute
whatever the [__] you
know but it's big to apologize it just
takes it off your soul you know even if
it's you made three years ago or
something that that person probably
doesn't even
remember you know you made a comment in
The Green Room one
night about a joke or something stupid
you were having a bad night you know and
that's what it [__]
is so was it was it like you talking to
Kent that made you start a apolog like
when did you start apologizing to Kent
to anybody you just said like has it
always been big for you
uh I think when I was in my
30s I started saying you know hey what
the
[__] you know we're not
perfect you're GNA make mistakes you
know sometimes people make honest
mistakes they weren't thinking at the
time you know I've been there I know
what it's like to have [__] on your mind
mind and you're
like whatever you know but who gives a
[__] about apologizing we're talking
about doing things so we need to
apologize every once in a while you put
a firecrack up somebody's ass or
something you
know AB [__] lutely so yeah I
uh what like I I thought of you this
weekend because I did remember when I
went to go see Bad Santa and you yelled
at me yes I I pull I made a mistake my
girlfriend and her friends wanted to go
to a like this city put together like a
winter wonderland sort of thing right
food trucks and all that [__] and we got
there we drove an hour in everyone was
excited and there's a 40 minute line to
get in but then we all we could have
gone in because I went up to the
security guard just I didn't think this
would happen but he was like for 30
bucks I'll let all of you guys in right
now like oh [__] they're still like that
iy cuz we almost we just ended up going
to get dinner instead thank God but it
was I thought of you like this security
guard just charging and I would have
done it six bucks a
person did you do it no we didn't do it
we went just went to dinner instead
because it was freezing I just thought
about me telling you that I went to like
a wonder wonderland when I called you on
the phone I could tell you up to
something stupid you were stuttering you
weren't I I could always tell when
you're up to something stupid you know
like you're like yeah first of all the
phone rang like eight times so you got
to compose yourself to pick up the phone
after about a minute on the phone you I
go listen dog it's Saturday night what's
going on with the training we're doing
here we're always in training you know
what I'm saying anytime when we're in
training I do I do but then I fall
asleep at 50 c concerts I do do that
that's perfect that's perfect I go to a
50 Cent concert I just want to fall
asleep myself wake me up before you
leave you went to a 50 Cent cut and fell
asleep again you know just tap out just
say it ain't happening I'm not going
happen what no I fell asleep because I
was in
training well you were too much training
and obviously the music wasn't getting
to you because if you were jumping up
and down with the brothers you would
have been
you oh been puking on everybody I I I
was I I got [__] chicken fingers I
was so high
that's the only thing I did at the whole
concert I just walked at 50 Cent concert
yeah you got chicken fingers at a 50
Cent
conent I wasn't the only one but they
they had like I saw someone blame else
don't blame blame but I was I was really
high sometimes you just need everybody
else jumped off the building so I jumped
off the building like a m that I am you
know all you want to be Hamas and
[__]
flight the [__] is wrong with
[Laughter]
you you go to a 50 Cent concert that's
your that's like you
know I don't know that's like Jesus type
mistake and then from there you get
[__]
chick out you know what's a Jesus
mistake he should have stayed home
Thursday night yeah he should have taken
a n off but he's like no I gotta go out
I gotta face these people he would have
stayed home it would have been a
different world right now we would have
all been wearing cotton shorts floating
around you know there would have been no
Adam there wouldn't been no Eve whatever
the [__] oh I think Adam and Eve were
before Jesus the what I think Adam and
Eve were before Jesus were they
not listen who I I don't know the
chicken come before the egg I don't know
I thought Jesus created everything I
thought when Jesus came there was like
40 people on the Earth and [__] 22 Jews
and eight [__] gypsies you know and
three Gentiles I think so I think that's
what it was but like I think I think
that because there's before Christ and
AFA I don't know I'm really yeah but
whenever you watch like a Jesus movie
right because the producers are like
listen this ain't gonna work you know
unless we get it you know the Jesus
story is told over and over so you can't
really add to it that's why when Mel
Gibson kicked the [__] out of the dude
and threw him out of window that got
some reviews you know like that that's
what they need they need they need to
see something Jesus getting stabbed
punched whatever but any [__] Jesus
thing you watch which I enjoy those
things from time to time it's always
like a small array of extras because the
producers know this is a bomb why are we
gonna just shift them around you know
what I'm saying like move the [__] C
over there move the [__] herder over
there geez I I remember when that Mel
Gibson movie came out cuz like like our
Temple because they were like he's going
to say that the Jews kill Jesus and
there's going to be problems like they
were like worried about it did he say it
I have no I I never saw that movie to be
honest with you it's disturbing but you
gotta take a chance Columbus did
[__] I can't do that te doesn't he
get like [__] like beat up beat up in
that movie like they don't hold back
beat up in real life they [__] you
know they threw him off a cliff they
kicked him this is before the Israelis
had missiles they just had those [__]
heavy boots with the points like Puerto
Ricans do now and they kick in the ribs
and [__] like
that anyway let me tell you something
anyway I don't want to wish the week I
had last week on
anybody that was [__] brutal guys I
don't even know how I did that podcast
with you guys last
week I must have just kept it together
for an hour and a half
yeah because you didn't seem like you
were
struggling no because I had like 22
eles I had some [__] Silly Willy milk
chocolate it's time
[__] I don't know if I should do
this or the the cookie because these are
four grams but the cookies are three
grams so if I gota eat six grams tonight
woo
lordy Jesus so you already had some I
already had a
cookie oh damn but I got nothing
tomorrow I did everything I had to do
today perfect which wasn't much you know
emails I had to do some videos [__] like
that Wednesday I got some
dentist and uh then it's thanks [__]
giving guys Happy Thanksgiving to all
the people who check in on Tuesdays with
us it's been a [__] great couple
months and we're g to keep the train
going I'm just excited that I'm doing
something I'm excited that I get to see
my buddy and I'm thankful I'm thankful
for [__] uh all you guys [__] Lisi
at the Flying Jew and uh you know the
whole [__] thing we got to hide them
from the Palestinians now people
boycotting the podcast and [__] but
gives a [__] chck we do our
thing we were so big in Palestine no
we're big everywhere like last week I
don't even know like I got I must to
finish here with you guys first off I
slept
downstairs for five [__] nights in
the reclining
chair listen okay I've slept in a prison
cell you know there's things that are
worse but not when you're [__] 60
years old you're in a recliner and then
I would do Edibles at night mushrooms
and and had those edible chocolate bars
I had a bunch of [__] going on last week
so it took help me deal with the [__]
pain and the swelling and [__] but I
would get so high at night that I'd turn
the light off and I'd recline the chair
right with my feet up and then I'd wake
up in the middle of night to pee but I'd
be like holy [__] the power went on the
roller
coaster like I thought it was at I
thought I was on a roller coaster and
the [__] chair was just hanging the
top one up in the sky so I would sit
there for like five minutes going how
the [__] am I gonna get down from here
that happened to me like two nights in a
row I'm like I'm so high I'm on a
[__] roller coaster and finally I'm
like Joey turn the light on I turned the
light on there I was
I lowered the thing I took a B I had a
pee in a [__] bottle for Five Guys
two in the chair the whole time the what
you just in the chair all day I was in
the chair the whole day what saved me
was that uh I had some Codine with tylol
and I was eating those but I didn't eat
the pro well let's get to that so I
didn't go to the bathroom for like four
days I wasn't eating much because the
pain was giving me nausea so I thought
it was because I wasn't eating much and
I go holy [__] I was taking those codin
and my brother came by and dropped two
[__] oxies on me so I didn't have
legitimate pain pills I had like a week
of like a Puerto Rican week like I had
Tylenol Ali then I had
aoxy then [__] my neighbor gave me
two perco setes and then I was like I'm
done with that [__] you know like once I
started feeling them kicking into my
psyche I go that's it I'll deal with the
pain the rest of the [__] time
but I was peeing in the bottle and then
one night I got so high and my wife left
me downstairs with just like three
bottles of water and I'm [__]
starving at like 12 o'clock so there was
a jar and I thought it was vitamin C
these
gummies and I go in there and I'm eating
these things like they're [__] yum
yum and the next thing you [__] know
I turn them around they're
probiotics so
I I ate three fingers of probiotics
there was like maybe eight gummies left
on the bottom I ate the whole thing I
went to sleep you woke me
up going down my block the whole [__]
revolving chair was shaking I had to get
up and I started [__] all day so
with the bad ankle I had a [__] all
[__] day pull my pants down get on
the toilet with one leg like a [__]
pelican like an ostrich whatever you
call those animals a crane I don't
[__]
know it was guys it was rough Saturday
Sunday and Monday I took Puerto Rican
showers with the bucket and the sponge
and [__] like that which that don't do
nothing you know I mean it takes the
armpit it takes the nut sweat away you
clean your hat but the [__] was clean
as a whistle nothing was going in or out
of there you know what I'm saying so I
had no
fck but man all day Tuesday I [__]
Tuesday and Wednesday the probiotics
clean me me out I had to go to the
bathroom every eight minutes on the bum
[__] leg so that was torture and how
many are you supposed to have a day of
that do you know like two of them I like
38 yeah you know me I'm [__] [__]
half [__] you know how we do it what
felt worse the foot or doing that
because that like [__] all day
that's not good dog I I [__]
Wednesday I got up and finally I got in
the car with my wife and I went to
acupuncture
and she [__] stuck a bunch of needles
in me and my ears my other knee and then
she wrapped my leg and she said don't
change it till tomorrow she wrapped it
so tight that it pushed all the [__]
fluid out of the leg and then I was okay
Thursday Friday Saturday I was walking
around a little more I was showering
those days you know I could stand in the
shower and [__] no pain pills no nothing
I missed my friend's wake you know I
Erica Florentine I missed her her
sister's uh wedding which I want to
congratulate Leah and her husband they
got married on Friday ni I miss that but
what I really missed was bonee head's
brother's wife died two weeks ago jod
and I was supposed to go to that on
Saturday and I couldn't do that on
Saturday because I couldn't drive I
couldn't drive 10 minutes never mind an
hour Sunday I just drove up and down the
block to my neor neighborhood and then
today I didn't get on the nine yet I
will not get on the nine yet but I just
drove around these other you know 45 M
hour streets just till I get the [__]
leg the hook the hoof [__] going you
know what I'm saying because you heard
it right where like you move it to move
the pedal yeah I hurt the [__] right
ankle so you know hey man I I did
everything I had to do I rubbed the pain
cream on it I did therapeutic massages
my wife I put ice on it three or four
times a day I put an Epson salt I
[__] rubbed it with a gun to break up
all the fascia and stuff so like I said
today was my first day I went back to
the
gym I didn't do a lot of leg stuff but
he put me through the [__] ringer as
usual so let's see what happens tomorrow
I'll take the day off maybe ride the
stationary bike to get the metabolism
going again
and then [__] do our thing I did get
a writer for the TV show for the book so
I'm very excited about
that at least now I got something to do
you know I was really concerned about
2024 in my world and in a lot of
people's world right now you should be
looking forward to 2024 like right now
come on after Thursday it's Jingle Bells
from most [__] people and who's not
going to their grandmothers for
Christmas and who's got to go Christmas
shopping so it's very tough to do
business with focused [__] people you
know you're not going to meet a lot of
people that are Focus so in your mind
right now as a young comic or whatever
you're done you're already booked to the
year if you're gonna do New Years you
know by now if you're gonna open you
know by now I'm not saying that there's
not a lot of late gigs that open up
there'll be a ton of late gigs that open
up people try to do Chinese restaurant
[__] uh Christmas day you know
Christmas Eve whatever the [__] it is
but right now I want you to live in the
moment but I also want you to start
looking at 2024 and that's why last week
was a silver
lining because I couldn't do it I knew I
couldn't do anything so I started
outlining the book I knew I couldn't do
anything so I got on the horn with my
agent and we interviewed a couple
writers I talked to a few writers and I
finally pick one and uh at least I made
[__]
nothing into something and at least I'm
GNA do something in 2024 I got it lined
up I spoke to Erica today I want to wish
her a happy birthday we're going to
start putting the comedy book together
in January so you know think of a year
after that till it comes
out and uh writing with this young TV
writer getting some ideas hopefully
we'll get a show runner soon and uh the
podcast so at least I'll have something
going on you to follow me something that
I'm working towards so 2024 is complete
for me I'm always going to be a [__]
dad 2024 2028 so that that's uh without
going so at least I got my year planned
out it's kind of cool because I don't
know if you remember this but you
probably do like you would like as you
were we were like leaving La you kept
saying like I'd love to be able to like
to write like you talked about WR
writing a lot and you've always enjoyed
it and you kind of took a break from it
for like you always writing with a book
but like you didn't do blogs and now
like you're writing two
things well I'm not writing two things
I'm helping I mean I know you're not
like the one typing it down but it's
your story yeah well you know I just try
to outline it the best you can I'm
trying to outline it the needs of young
Comics I'm trying to think of what my
needs were as a young comic but that was
also
1990 so a lot has changed the internet
has entered so I have to cover that also
in this book which I'm new to also so
this is where I'm I'm finding a problem
but the basics will always be the
same the basics the same you I mean
you you know so much about stuff that
will always be the same like you said
and the new stuff like you know
I I know like you're not like super
technical but like I feel like you are
one of the better comedians on the
internet I think you can give at least
from your P I'm not thinking it's going
to work for everybody but you have a
system I
think um listen you all you the first
seven or six years you don't have a
system you're experimenting as a young
comic you're just experimenting you know
do I do this and we just we spoke about
this before whether it's wardrobe
whether it's
you're just always experimenting and
then you find the Rhythm you know what I
didn't really like writing in the
daytime anyway I did a lot better when I
wrote at night when I came home from
doing my set when I was doing coke you
know as I was getting high and then you
could see where I started getting higher
and higher it became gibberish you know
like but the first three lines six lines
were there the basics are always going
to be the same but now as an open micer
there's different ways to attack things
you know now you got to go on Instagram
and they put the the schedules up and
you know I don't know about this so far
this is why I was telling you about open
mics that I got to start going to them
to see how this is going down right
now well I mean I I also think though
it's like kind of there's a difference
like I like I've met like I did open
mics in Jersey when I was there with you
I've done them all over I think there's
like a different between people who just
want to like not skip the line but get
famous pretty quick and I think there's
people who take comedy seriously and I
think like the stuff the book is like
the most important stuff is for the
people who are taking it Ser I mean I I
think don't you think like it's like
that your advice is going to talk to
them we have we have a mainstream
problem that everybody wants to be
famous they don't know what comes along
with it they don't know know how what to
do to get
there but they just woke up one day and
decided they wanted to be famous now
when I got into standup I didn't want to
be famous I just wanted to be a good
standup so those are the differences of
how you have to look at things the first
chapter in this book is going to cover
why why standup are you looking because
I just want you to know what you're
getting yourself
into you know everybody sees Rogan and
Dave Chappelle hanging out with stars
and rappers and you see [__] sagur
with Jason Mamoa and and you sit there
at home in your [__] little basement
apartment like I did hoping that someday
that would be me you know that's gonna
be me someday I'm gonna have [__] in
a boat you know you know this J giberish
that young men talk about and you don't
even think about why you're doing
it it took me three years years to to
realize why I did all that work I didn't
really want to be a comic I wanted to be
a man and that was the easiest way for
me to become a man did I know that when
I started this no because if I told you
I wanted to be a famous comic I'd still
be on the stage right now you know going
head-to-head with these guys starting to
get into Arenas right now that would
have been my life's work but after I
started staying home and I always told
people listen it's tough to put your
sneakers on if you can't do a set for
free forget about getting paid for it
and this is what was bothering me about
my last three or four years in comedy it
wasn't like something I enjoyed I could
come up with material like anybody I
wasn't a traditional writer you know
when I started dipping into myself and
telling stories and comparing them to
life today that's when things started to
click
but by that time I was like okay I got
the answer I got a kid now you know I
want to be home I want to be around for
that kid now that you know as a comic if
Mercy's 10 right now I'd see Mercy four
weekends I don't want to do that so
somewhere along the line I realized I
didn't want to be famous you know I hate
all that [__] I hate premieres and Hall
of Fame Banquets you know I didn't go to
David Chase's Hall of Fame thing I hate
all that stuff guys I just wanted to be
a man I just thought comedy would be the
easiest way did I write that down in
that gold notebook the first three or
four or five no I didn't that's why I'm
the me I'm in the mess I'm in right now
when are you getting back on stage I'm
not because I don't need to get on stage
anymore the job was done so we all have
a purpose and I want you to hit that
purpose before you waste your time on
this if you want to be famous you're 15
years away and trust me in my mind I
know you look at that number and
go I'll become a piano player well go do
that or I'll become a model I'll become
a professional party person go do that
if you do strike Fame is that it's going
to be Fame for two
months this type of success where you
put the work in and pay attention this
goes forever I can make a comeback
tomorrow if I want to you know get an
hour's worth of material because I did
the work I know how it's
done pretty plain and [__] simple and
then we're going to build on that from
there you know I don't want look at
Kevin Hart and Chappelle and you know
Shane Gillis you know the big comics of
today Whitney Cummings the elijas and go
I want that
life you know I'm going to do this
you're doing it for the wrong reasons I
don't know I didn't it to get high to
disappear to get a PO Box you know I did
it for those reasons who I you know when
you hear those stories the [__]
had a page you till 200 [__]
three you
know probably didn't even want to get
rid of it at that point no I didn't get
into comedy for that reason to be at VIP
rooms taking pictures I like the store
that's I was supposed to be there you
know what I'm saying it's not like I
wasn't supposed to be there I would have
two spots a night there so I was
supposed to be l so it felt good when I
see pictures from the store that's not
too bad it's not like I'm jumping up and
down but you never saw me pictures from
events or nothing like that I strayed
from those things I don't want you know
so I always had the I was always on the
right Road for
myself if you want [__] let me know
I'm not going to be mad at you if you
pull me aside and go listen I want to go
on the road to get my dick suck seven
nights a week
okay at least you know why you're doing
it but remember one night when your
right nut falls
off you can't do [__] comedy no more
that's all and I don't give a [__] what
you get into but get into it for the
right reasons not
because you you know that's the HIIT job
right
now I think there's probably a lot of
people who started standup after the
podcast
started like since Rogan started I I
would guess like there's way more
standups there's an explosion in this
country there's an explosion of standup
and entertainment and I love it I love
it I just want them to know what they
get themselves
into you know last week I I think I made
a statement to you or to somebody that I
can't wait till somebody makes a remark
after the strike and today I saw the
first
one there was some woman saying the
strike's been over for two weeks and I
still haven't had an audition
well what did you think was going to
happen the sky was just going to open up
with [__] scripts and auditions we're
going back to where we started from you
gotta remember there's a war going on
there's two Wars and there's no tax
breaks and everything is expensive as
[__]
now you know what do you think these
people look how many shows they got rid
of did they cancel a lot of
shows don't ask me which one
specifically these are things I just
heard they just and they and were they
getting a lot of auditions before the
strike
no they were just like me they were
bumed then and they're a bum
now you you did not hear me say to you
the last two weeks I'm sitting here
waiting by the phone for an audition I
knew life was gonna be just the way it
was before the [__]
audition so did the strike do anything
what's that brother did the strike
accomplish
anything Le I didn't get the details you
know what I'm saying they don't send me
the
memo
I know I got some from them
today I got a bill last
week and I got my new membership
card nice big [__]
deal I still can't get over the fact how
many of those uh probiotics you ate is
that were you just eating more
probiotics what's that brother what was
that a [__] silly mushroom [__] oh
[__] what's that app called
Telegraph I guess so there's an app
called is there an app called
Telegraph
telegram make up your [__] mind
telegram Telegraph I'm sure there's apps
called both I don't know which one
you're talking about is it like a
texting app yes
okay I can find out but then I got to
get up and burn calories and slip on the
[__] carpet will you go to telegram
or
Telegraph I think it's telegram yeah
yeah it's telegram Telegram and you look
up [__] uh Fun Factory
farms and you could order some mushrooms
they'll deliver
them just put Co yeah remember I told
you a couple weeks ago you just put the
thing Uncle Joey Savage and you get 10%
off not bad car look the holiday
season's coming and I gotta tell you
something I'm [__]
excited I am very excited Thanksgiving
said that I'm gonna go to the gym I'm
gonna come back I'm gonna smoke some
dope and I'm going across the
street I'm gonna [__] eat over there
and then I'm gonna close out the night
around the corner at my other friend's
house right in the neighborhood I don't
even have to take my car off the street
all [__]
day and then I go to my in-laws for
[__]
Christmas oh [__] how okay and I
gotta we're leaving
like I don't know the 22nd the 23rd and
coming back to 26 or something it's like
three days four days because we got a
bunch of [__] going on so but I'm
excited about that we're flying jxx
jsx that's what it's called done that
before no this is my first time I've
heard a lot of good things about it
let's see they better be on [__] time
that's all I give a [__] about if you
watch the TV tonight I had to turn it on
just to get the bad news not for me just
to [__] verify what I've been telling
people for 30 years when it comes to the
holiday I know your grandmother's got
another year to live but don't get on
that Southwest FL what I'm saying mind
your [__] business okay everybody
wants to run home during that you know
it's going to be another record year
travel they couldn't handle it in
[__] July what do you think they're
gon to fall apart listen the the [__]
again I'm worried about the American he
gets up on Monday he goes to work and he
takes a week vacation out of his kick to
leave on Tuesday to leave early he's
probably gonna been three hours delayed
they're gonna lose his wig they're gonna
lose Mama's [__] box then you get
there you do your five days and then you
gotta come home now remember you're
spreading out three days of travel
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday where
Wednesday being the high day Monday
Tuesday Wednesday would Wednesday being
record [__] numbers but today they
were record
numbers so you I hear violins the
mushroom so you got three days to pack
out 150,000 200,000 people but now
they're all coming home on Sunday right
what do you think's GNA happen
tears wait get wait wait till you get up
Sunday on Twitter on Twitter it'll be on
X whatever the [__] you call it there'll
be people complaining [__] United
where's my luggage American Air Alonzo
Bowden will definitely be at war with
American an he's always at war with
American an you know there's like eight
Comics where's my luggage I should have
stayed in my hotel room [__] you America
yeah that's what you'll see because it's
just mathematics
it took three days to fly out these
animals and now they're going to all
come back in one [__]
day or at
least 75% of them right and like even
with all all those people like what do
you think about like there's been like a
lot of crazy [__] happening on airplanes
like are going crazy [__] pack you in
like sardines they've cut your seat down
your rest have you ever sat in the
toilet too small for you oh a lot you
know what I'm saying like you think
you're G to fall off the [__] planet
don't you so now think you know it's
just they flying used to be a lot of fun
now it's not fun it's a [__] you
gotta be prepared you gotta [__] take
a Xanax you know you gota you don't know
what's gonna happen they're gonna take
you out of your seat like the Chinese
guy and then [__] beat you up on ABC
News you
know it takes a lot man it takes a lot
to fly I don't have it anymore I already
put my [__] mileage in across this
country 82 times I'm done I don't need
to go anywhere I need to go see I love
my uncle 85 years old we talk once a
month you know what I ain't going there
till maybe March if something happens
with the TV show that's when I'll fly
back to LA but I'm not going to LA to
walk around and say hello to Mickey
those days are [__] ended Mickey can
suck my dick back you see that guy the
other day that got chased or some [__]
he went to his apartment and two guys
jumped over the wall and he [__]
threw his coffee at one guy and they
pulled the gun out and he had a a
licensed gun registered the whole
[__] deal and the other guy went away
but I think he took two shots at him and
now they're revoking his license this is
America oh yeah like what yeah now you
[__] you know some guy jumps the wall
you pull out your [__] real piece
that you you know this kid's a nice
white kid he's not an animal like me
you know this kid goes to church he
[__] wears a yam on Sundays whatever
the [__] he does he does
both I heard of that story but like the
way you were describing it I didn't
didn't remember that that guy was like
protecting his own house yes yes he was
protecting his own house and not even in
the valley where we were he was down
there with white people drinking
cappuccinos and lattes and walking dogs
are the small and ugly you know and you
got to make believe the dog is
cute
oh my God a [__] Mouse on his leash
and I love your ponies yeah I paid three
grand for well really I got a mouse I
dug out of the backyard that'll eat your
[__] [__] all right speaking of
flying did you ever which one there's a
movie where a dog fought a [__]
rat anyway must have been a Chinese
movie go Ahad but speaking of like pets
like La people in pets did you ever fly
with someone like with a dog or a cat in
their lap next to you because that I
can't imagine not next to because I'll
threaten I stopped one lady one time and
I go tell that dog not to [__] on the
plane because if they [__] on the plane
then they gotta lower the plane evacuate
everybody and put you on a different
plane did you know that if a cat pisses
or a dog pisses they got to bring the
plane down yeah I mean just happened
with a human a couple months ago I think
it was Ralphie B was on on a plane where
dog went bananas and started [__]
all over the aisles [__] and he was
stuck for six hours somewhere he
couldn't get home because the dog [__]
all over the place listen if you're
thinking a flying during the [__] uh
holidays do yourself a favor and contact
my
friends over at better help and here's a
little advertisement for them and
remember if you don't want to hear the
voices pay attention to this
ad yo this episode is brought to you by
better help listen the holiday Blues are
no joke it seems like everybody except
for you is enjoying the Most Wonderful
Time of the Year listen to me speaking
to somebody can help better yet therapy
can help better helps
online therapy makes it easy to get
started it just take a quiz a quick quiz
and better help team will match you with
a license therapist you can connect with
them over video chat over the phone or
even by message so it's convenient and
totally suited for your schedule listen
it's the holidays guys everybody feels
at least a little something they lost
their grandmother a dog got hit by a car
it's always something listen I've had
issues I went to better help and here I
am two years later feeling like a doctor
as much as you might love chatting with
your friends or a significant other
reaching out to a trained therapist is a
total game Cher for your men the so do
me a a favor be a good friend to
yourself take care of yourself this
holiday season and for 2024 find your
bright spot this season with better help
visit betterhelp.com
Diaz di to get 10% off your first month
that's going to help you out a lot again
that's better
help better help
hp.com Diaz myself Lee and better help
wish you a Happy Thanksgiving now back
to the show all right that was your
little better help whatever you want to
do that we don't discuss here listen if
you're doing it just go to better help
they'll straighten you out run it by the
therapist listen say look at I got
problems I want to fly back to see my
grandmother one leg let mind your
business go back in April it's 20% off
the flights you get money off the rental
car you're gonna go back there you know
it's not worth it anymore
it's not worth that suffering and I
[__] you know I just realized like
I'm going to my in-laws for
Christmas I wish I would have done that
when I lived in La that was a mistake we
both
made and like what part of it not coming
home for either or got it okay yeah we
didn't we never did like as much [__] as
I talk I regret it now because those
Christmases were [__] brutal those
Thanksgiving were [__] brutal they
you know those people out there they
don't know how to celebrate dick so you
know every celebration unless Tom sagur
is gonna be there or or Scott Van Fleet
or something then it's not going to
really matter they're not [__] happy
I went to one Thanksgiving in in La like
in 2002 it was the worst Thanksgiving I
ever had in my life they stuck the
[__] duck inside a turkey and then
they made jail mashed potatoes I was
like that's it
never again you can't [__] make jail
white people love those prison potatoes
listen they're good when they're needed
okay but even if make potatoes out of a
box do me a favor dope them up put some
milk in that [__] throw a stick
of butter in it give it some flavor make
me die for a heart attack but don't make
watered [__] potatoes and then
they're like you know anyway I'm sorry
about that little but didn't you have
talking PSI L Ys sillies look them up on
telegram Telegraph whatever the [__] it
is and Uncle Joey Savage capital letter
U JS how's that for you tip tip Meo
anyway what were you saying there my
little
[__]
Marksman [__] I I had
um what were you just talk because I had
something damn
it I'm I'm a little high anyway what's
the comedy plan for the week it's
Tuesday tonight tonight I tonight I have
maybe mics I think some mics are
canceled because like it's going to be
Halloween stuff I Halloween Thanksgiving
stuff um but then Saturday I have a show
in Cambridge and Sunday I have a show at
the comedy Connection in
Providence you know things are
really like there's another thing I got
to put in the book I remember moving to
7 and from
97 till about
2003 I worked every Thanksgiving at a
bar in Huntington Beach maybe one of
those beaches down there you know how
much they paid me how much 40
bucks for how
long 25 minutes that's pretty good on
Thanksgiving I mean I I I don't even get
paid most of the time now so I guess
probably not when you're actually trying
to like make a living this is 1998
99 I did it until the you know that year
where I was just talking about that
Thanksgiving where they gave us to
truncan right that's the year I finally
canceled on them I'm not coming down I
called him like it's quar eight I got
car problems you'll never work in
Hollywood again go [__] yourself he had
a room down there he had a room in that
town by us oh
high but it was on a Sunday bunch of
[__] yahoos it was a next to ohigh
and it was just a bunch of yahoos on
Sunday night toothless people people
with
banjos [__] you know
so I didn't give a [__] I canceled that
was it but I always did the night before
Thanksgiving and this is the first year
it's gonna be like the for like last
year we did it yeah we did parks and
then the the year before that I
didn't but every year before that Lee
tell them about those drives
man those drives to Irvine on yeah
Thanksgiving
Eve first of all the show would start at
8 we'd have to leave like at
4:30 and it would be Bumper to Bumper
the whole way down there and we'd be
smoking eating Edibles yelling beeping
the
horn and everybody me you di austino
whoever was working Steve Simone we'd
all get in the car remember we went down
there one year and we had unami Burger
and everybody got
sick I don't think I I don't I think I
think I heard about that but I don't
think I was that was those were [__]
crazy rides because yeah you would I
used to bomb at Irvine no you
didn't every [__] and then they start
I would sell so many tickets that they'
add shows so I would go down there for a
double bomb all those Thanksgiving I go
down there a double bomb they already
knew I was coming down night before
Thanksgiving just to sit there and stare
at me but I didn't give a [__] for the
amount they were paying me then it was a
big contrast of the
$45 I was making for all those years
that's why I kept going down that they
were giving you top dollar on a
Wednesday night I'm like dog I can't
pass this up to hang out with a bunch of
Mormons talking about turkey I gota go
pick up that [__] paper like Biggy
Smalls and [__] 95 so that's the only
reason why I go down there because they
go all out and pay me they would never
pay me but they pay me to go down there
I was the only dumb enough person to go
down there and take a beating on the
Wednesday before Thanksgiving that's
what my dignity was I didn't give a [__]
just give my envelope I got [__] to do
why was it taking a
beaten Irvine never liked
me Irvine and me never really got along
do you know what I'm
saying am I wrong or did we no we didn't
record the priest there we did that at
onario maybe or bre was my bre was my
favorite [__] improv in
California then they opened up the one
by a house and we did that one after the
holidays before New Year's that's the
one we had to carry a dad at on ter was
arvine or Oxnard that was Oxnard oh that
was Oxnard you're right
Oxnard where Kishi came with the tight
bike pants on and your dad [__] we
had to carry him out like hysterical
these guy I'm telling you Stars
Wednesday night before Thanksgiving to
me is the best night of the year since I
was a kid I would lose my mind that's
when I just that's why I learned how to
sell Coke the Wednesday nights when
everybody came home from college that
first year I felt like Matt low in that
movie movie uh that he did about the
college people I was like the bad egg
they would come home like oh my God we
just did Ruckus really well snort this
[__] this will put you on a different
planet so I remember night huh I it was
funny that you learned it the night
before Thanksgiving yeah because
everybody comes home from college
everybody goes out everybody puts a new
t-shirt on for T I think people get more
dressed up the Wednesday before
Thanksgiving the New Year's
Eve that's everyone goes home
[__] how'd you do this weekend
anything I I I did five spots last week
all open
mics did you bet New England anything
happened for you last week yeah yeah I
got I got a couple good ones actually I
got really lucky on draft gangs last
night because I I I won a couple I put
like 40 bucks and I got it like 100
and then I lost a bunch and I just put
the rest on the under for the
Vikings uh Denver game Denver game last
night and it was 41 and a half and
[__] Denver scored but they went for
two and didn't get the two so because of
that I was under by half a
point was [__] that was a that's like
why you bet because I was watching the
whole time I put one betting this
weekend yeah Houston
and they didn't cover they won by five
they were given five and a
half and I [__] up because I don't
have the football package I watched it
at Jimmy's house but Jimmy went to Miami
to see the jet uh the Dolphins play Las
Vegas so I [__] up I couldn't watch
the game I'll just go to jimmies and go
upstairs and I would have watched the
Texans but I tell you what's been giving
me money lately Lee what's that
DraftKings
Casino I love the that's my favorite
part coming to Jersey that wheel of
[__] that wheel of [__] whatever
wheel of
forun dog but I don't play I play at odd
hours like if I wake up in the middle of
night with insomnia I'll hit that bong
three or four times and I'll [__]
just play dollars for [__] an hour
and dog you always win after like $69
$70 you start
hitting and you spend some of yeah it's
it's you have to spend some money and
then hit take a little beating and then
be patient because boom you'll [__]
catch it then but yeah I didn't nothing
I haven't really been
basketball I don't really know the teams
I thought the [__] Dallas would be
good they're getting beat up the
Clippers got this All-Star team which I
knew wasn't going to work but they've
lost a bunch in a row Milwaukee's got an
All-Star team they can't put it together
you know it's just
been so maybe I'm getting old who the
[__] the only one I watch is the Celtics
and they've been doing pretty well
Celtics always do well I watch this if
the Celtics are on TV especially against
the Sixers because I got the Sixers here
yeah those have been good games I get
Boston no I get the Sixers I get uh
Brooklyn and I get the
Knicks and I can't watch the Knicks of
Brooklyn but I watch the Sixers all
[__] day long my man Max's on the
Sixers so but Boston I was just talking
to uh one of the kids on my uh around
the corner he's joh he's Luke Florentine
friend and we were talking about how
Boston already played Philly twice in
Philly this
year but The Season's a month old
they've already I'm not going to see
Boston this year unless I go to the
Garden or to
Brooklyn
and they were good games that's crazy
that they scheduled them so close to
each other I went to one of the Boston
games last year I always try to catch
Boston every year I'm not telling you
I'm a Boston fan but if you're gonna
gonna watch a game and get your money's
worth you might as well go go see Boston
I hate that they traded away Maxwell
Smart the black dude with the pink hair
and [__] you know yeah their reasons but
I'm gonna miss him Marcus Smart Marcus
Smart
Marcus but anyway here's the second
break break I'm going to talk to you
people about DraftKings Thursday
Thanksgiving gobble Goble you got bowl
games you got basketball games you got
college basketball games this is the
time of the year check me out with
DraftKings got suck Thanksgiving is the
best you get to eat like a pig fart
scratch your balls and maybe even win a
buck or two which DraftKings listen new
customers sign up today you can bet five
bucks on NFL a ction and score 150
instantly in bonus bets go ahead and bet
before you hit the Black Friday sales no
matter what your appetite there's
something for you this weekend money
lines parlays same game parlays prop
live bets and so much more so do
yourself a favor download the DraftKings
Sportsbook app now and pressing code
Joey Joe y new customers bet five bucks
on the NFL Thanksgiving action to score
150 instantly in bonus bets where you
going to get that DraftKings an official
sports betting partner of the NFL with
Co Joey at DraftKings the crown is yours
but do me a favor you got a gambling
problem call 1 1800 Gambler in New York
call
8778 Hope New York or text Hope New York
if not listen it's Happy Thanksgiving do
your best and have a great time remember
this is all about fun but starts by
downloading the draftking Sportsbook app
now and pressing Cod Joey Happy
Thanksgiving and now it's back to the
show we're back [__] what's up Lee
what do you got going on next week or
this week you got spots Wednesday you
got I got some but I'm really EXC I'm
going I'm featuring for uh Josh at the
Kansas City improv next week at the end
of the month the 30th through the 2nd
yeah that's good [__] they got good food
they got a good kickboxing school over
there my man from the UFC oh yeah boxing
school that's a fun [__]
Club Kansas City I've always love
Columbus there's just some clubs that
are fun three
days yeah days you know you're really
going to be busy if you try Cleveland my
boy Nick I love that [__] room we
used to go over to the try place on
Fridays the hotel's got the chocolate
bar with the chocolate milkshakes and
the chocolate martinis oh Jesus Christ
at the hotel at the hotel the chocolate
bar I would come home all three nights
and get a chocolate shake listen to me
even the straw is [__] chocolate
Jesus Christ it's one of those type of
places do you have a barbecue place in
Kansas
City no but it's everywhere and the
staff will tell you if you were in
Cleveland right across the street from
the club 40 yards there's a high-end
[__] or there was there was a
high-end [__] barbecue place the
brisket
sandwich woo smoking jack I I [__] I
can't wait I love brisket I but I've
gotten to do like all the not all but
yeah I did like with you I I did the
store I did Cap City I did uh The Comedy
Works Cap City was fun Cap City was a
lot
when you wanted to eat Chinese food and
Bobby Sharon wouldn't let you I'm gonna
walk up to eat Chinese food Le now one
person ever comes back from Austin
better yet Texas and says I went to
Texas and had good Chinese food it just
don't happen every you know they killed
Chinese people every two years like what
happened to that guy Ming I don't
know listen I didn't this was before
Uber eids you bring this up every year
it was before Uber eids we were in the
middle of nowhere eats Uber Eats anyway
again they go through your French fries
they stick them in their nose when
they're driving and they put them back
on your plate that's you yeah but here's
the deal you have a rule when we when
when you travel that you're eating
within a block of the hotel there's not
much always within a block of the hotel
yeah but I and over there there is you
got Papacitos around the corner and you
got Papa do across the street so what
are you talking about plus you have a
whole restaurant what are you thought
plus I put you listen they would give
him cookies whenever he checked in he'd
take the big [__] cookies and take
him to his room like three of those
chocolate cookies how dare you say there
was nothing to eat cocksuck look you
didn't no I of course there was food to
eat and don't pretend like you weren't
getting any of those cookies those are
good double cookies Don't Make Believe
like you took me to the hot I'm not
saying I was starving I'm just saying I
wanted to not even a block away guys was
Papa do not even a block it was 40 yards
from the door yeah but how many times if
you're there for four days do you want
to go to Papa do every
day yes
every
yes you can switch it up you get the
gumball one day you get the [__]
other thing the other day then the other
day you get the salad with the crab meat
and the shrimp and then the last day you
get one of those [__] po boys or some
[__] that's it it's very easy to mix it
up me I go in and eat the same [__]
thing every day because that's how I
roll I'm old man I get the lobster bis
move over to the [__] uh shrimp and
crab lump salad with blue cheese
dressing you couldn't finish it I don't
care what gorilla went in there with me
he could not [__] finish the salads
at Papados and then we go to Papacitos
around the corner that was right around
the corn that was 100 yards from the
hotel and this Muk wants to take a
[__] Uber Eats with some greasy guy
named Bubba to the corner Chinese all
you could eat are you [__] crazy I
had enough shrimp I wanted something
different all you could eat Chinese
place is my man Jerry roacher when I was
a young buck and Jerry was even a
younger Buck he would take me to all you
could eat but they always had something
like one place had the big shrimp and
they'd fry them I would only eat the
shrimp you know I ain't touching that
rice with worms and [__] in
it the other place had good soup we used
to kill Chinese buffets but they're few
and far between you got to live there to
know which ones are the ones you're not
going to die from I taking you got to
assume you're gonna go to the hospital
you're gonna have a stomach cramp you're
gonna eat something that's not good you
got to assume if if you don't you're
[__] [__] it's like going to
crack a barrel you're gonna eat
something that's bad it may not even
belong to you it's not even a
restaurant's fault maybe some fat [__]
came up and and dipped her finger in the
[__] sauuce or something it could be
a lot of things so do you ever go to
Golden
Corral honestly yes I did in Burbank and
it
was the [__] most inedible food
you've ever seen in your life and to top
it all the people that were in there
were not from birbank they were like a a
mental
experiment they they had a in the house
and then they would bring him there and
tell him it was like [__] you know
dantas or something that was not good
that night that was not good I can't
believe you got talked into going there
my wife and me were just moved to the
valley and every Friday night we go on
like date night we and one night you
know you you see all the ads and people
are happy and they got f with the
[__] with the chocolate syrup ha well
we went there and nobody was haa all
right everybody had a look on their
[__] a look on their [__] face
like they just got let loose of the
[__] mental and to and they all and
the other people had to look on their
face like they needed ala salsa and I
know that [__] look all right so I I
couldn't eat nothing even the fountain
the chocolate fountain they advertised
with the it was
disgusting you messed that up huh how
why was it
gross it was just gross trust me you
don't want to put that [__] in your body
at that time I was a big boy I was like
330 six something yeah I went in there
and I was like this don't look good the
fish don't look good the shrimp don't
look good you know nothing look edible
and then you look at the stiffs that are
in there and you go look you know how do
you think they became stiffs they eat
here one night a
week the buffets do you you're not
really Buffet per I think you made fun
of me before for going to buffets you
know what
man when you're younger you love those
buffets yeah and one day you look at
them we like for me I had to be about 34
or something 35 when I went to a buffet
one then I what am I doing I got
problems I put drugs in my body and [__]
but this this is a different level and
guys listen when you're a broke comic on
the road you eat whatever when I'm
getting 600 a week and 200 for goes to
the plane ticket you got to eat whatever
you can you know Subway sandwiches with
no meat that was my favorite at least
even then I always ate the veggie veggie
and cheese I don't know what they made
the cheese out of over there but I took
my chances could be
turkey it could be something from a
turkey that cheese I don't know what it
is you know but you always try to and
then one day you don't need to eat that
way you go I'll never eat that way
again you know I didn't just get that
big For the Longest Yard that was a year
on the road Lee eating bar food whatever
they give you you're
broke you know whatever they give you
what do you what do you got well we got
fried chicken and onion rings so be it
and pack of box to go for the room
because Law and Order I don't want to be
lonely tonight when I'm e watching Law
and Order it's all you
know and then one day you go you know
what I can't eat the three [__] bags
a night of chips out of the out of the
machine it just starts with little
conscious
things but that's great because you were
probably doing
shows and like when you say broke like
you'll be lucky sometimes to like break
even for that show listen
man you know comedy always had uh I
always had to do extra things and I made
it through but you're not rocking and
rolling like me and my wife's first date
was that [__] Steakhouse on laa
that's not even there no more remember
that I don't know what it was called
Captain Fish or some [__] like that I
never went to it they give you like a
steak and hush puppies and you know it
was 30 I'll never forget it was like $26
for both of us you know and then you
just start looking at what works what's
not going to kill you doesn't take a
genius when you look at a [__] and the
McDonald's are all different like the
McDonald's by my house that's an a class
McDonald you go in there and get a
quarter pound of with cheese you [__]
die Lee you go holy [__] did this a
McDonald's bger well three weeks ago we
had a baseball tournament and the guy
went over there and he goes the only
thing that's open is McDonald's and he
brought back Quarter Pounders these
things were a day old oh yeah you come
over here and they [__] make them
right there the juice is coming out of
them you can't believe the quarter pound
in maror cannot [__] believe it it's
not like I'm there every weekend but
when they first opened I took my
daughter over there they had some
promotion thing and I took a quarter
pound if I'm going to go to hell I might
as well eat the I the only one who
really has real meat is the quarter
pounder I think red red band told me
that like it's actually like what is the
other
stuff it's like soy products or some
[__] you got to check it
out but I having a conversation with red
band about this that [__] you know
that's the only Burger he because he
likes fast food [__] yeah I love fast
food
but I was thinking about like we were
talking about stuff like that you know
who's killing it I think is Jesus tro
have you seen like how much stuff he's
done since we left
no he he wrote a
book a children's book yeah he's he's
like writing on a
show he he just did another special but
and like he like he's always been a
bright guy and you could see the guys
that are just he's killing it I think I
think that [__] uh Shane Gillis is
really [__] doing a great
job I'll tell you who's gonna squeak
past all these [__] I think
Paul
Rizzy really he's very funny he's very
funny that's a great special I watched
his football pick show with Bill Burr
Bill Burr is like half asleep Paul B's
carrying the show you know it's just
there's a lot of great Comics out there
I don't know much about the young guys
because it's like uh High School
football I don't know what's really G to
happen here but the guys that are just
getting momentum I keep my eye on those
guys you know like I remember Ralph
Barosa being a young guy like seeing him
like at the haa and stuff and he caught
on I don't remember Matt r at all I
remember his face but I don't remember
really working with him a lot you know
hey we moved I moved along you know the
pandemic came it changed the game of
Comedy it changed a lot of things the
pandemic looking back at it now
so we all [__] learned something my
friend you know what I'm
saying it's crazy but it's uh just
seeing all the people who like are
moving up it's just cool to see like you
know what was really cool I watched and
I haven't finished it yet but I watched
bill birs movie and they put the Brody
me uh Memorial on it it was just it's
just cool cuz I was thinking about you
with your TV and like Bill like all
these Comics are making movies now
there's been like four comics in the
past year that made M and [__] like that
just cool that to see everyone doing it
for
themselves I think I think Hollywood
also realized that listen whether the
whether the money well the movies made
money a lot a lot couple months ago I
went online for something and people are
banging Out birs movie that lost this
and lost that guys there's a ton of
movies now that lose money tons you know
and and it's not marketing it's not this
it's not that the movie theaters has
become a rough place to make people to
go
too you know it's it really has I could
talk to you about doing a show and
Sony Hall and push the stake on you and
say it's going to be a great time you're
right around the corner from this if you
take the ferry into the city you're
eight minutes from that it's a six
minute Uber ride you know I could sell
that to
you it's very rough to sell a [__]
movie theater to somebody
now both those movies came out and they
banged up against each
other Sebastian and and Bert had to go
up against each other that
weekend Memorial Day weekend you know I
think it rained here one day that we
Memorial Day is not what it used to be
for movies
anymore you know you see how much the
climate has
changed and it I think people also
expected to go to streaming eventually I
think that unfortunately that's going to
I went I I went and saw Bird's movie in
theater just CU I was I I wanted to go
see a movie and I love the theater but
it's I think it's gone to a point where
we we either buy it or stream it
eventually well I tried to buy Bert's
movie and it was like 28 bucks at first
and I was like I'll wait I think I just
saw Sebastian's on
Showtime okay one of channels picked it
up I watched his a couple of days ago
and I saw BS I don't know about a month
ago maybe a month and a half ago again
you know you're shooting
movies after Co I I don't know what's
going on with movies anymore I would
love to sit here and tell you
that I don't know I don't know where the
communication gap is with people anymore
I know that there's die hards like
myself yourself
Ari if a movie theater opened within an
hour from me not in the
city any other direction Pennsylvania
Cranford New Jersey one of those places
and they did a two
movie every Saturday night they were
looking for support you know from to
join a package I would
join I would definitely join I'm into
that I would go to the movies to sit
with other people who enjoy movies like
that and just watch a movie anyway from
Citizen Kane to Godzilla to [__] you
know it's great to watch those again and
with other people easier I'm sorry
oh I was going to say if you're the I
think the reason those places are
different is because people respect it
like they're not going to be like the
biggest problem right now at theater at
theaters I think is other
people and I think so like when you're
going to a place like that that's you're
like a member of or they're playing like
like not like current movies it's like
everyone there like Loves movies and
they wouldn't be like a an [__] in
the theater I gotta be honest with you
you know I go to the movie
twice a month now with Mercy you know I
didn't catch the Marvel one because my
ankle was [__]
up I never had a problem with the movies
want me to tell you
why yeah because there's never anybody
there never I go to two different movie
theaters either Freehold or East
Brunswick I both of them are you going
early in the
day I go look I went to see the
equalizer at night the last one with her
Thursday night opening night there was
six other people there in the movie
theater like you know when you sit in a
seat and you go [__] I hope nobody comes
over and says this is their seat there's
200 seats open but this is their [__]
seat you
know like it's been those like the
movies are empty flower Moon Flower Hill
whatever the [__] Leonardo Di Caprio
that had six people in it
that's crazy reho is a big movie place
and so is East
Brunswick I can't movies at East
Brunswick I've seen movies of both I
like them
both were they busy when you moved there
or have they been dead for a while well
when I moved here it was the pandemic so
nothing right I couldn't even get a
screening for the many Saints of
Newark and that was in 21 they were like
we don't know we don't have enough
people and then I found out what was
going on Lowe's whatever AMC they got
rid of a lot of people they even got rid
of the cleaning
crew damn managers and staffers have to
pick up the [__] in the theaters now
this is why about a month ago uh AMC and
Jersey City had a close down they had a
rap problem people were in there
watching a movie and they're getting
their toes bitten off by [__] little
hamsters
[__] that's why it happened because they
HED all the [__] custodia everything
that making the people who work there
pick the popcorn boxes and the [__] off
the [__] floor so put that gonna
happen
[__] it was crazy the movie
theater we used to pop it because I
worked there for years like we used to
pop it and they had like they like they
weren't like trash bags but they were
like food bags and they would just pop
them for
days and then they had warmers at the
front of the movie theater so like it
was it it wasn't
fresh like people like the hot dogs were
just like kind of weird eating anything
at the listen you're in a movie theater
now I [__] don't like popcorn and
movie there why this has been going on
for like 15 years that [__] imitation
butter everything has to be imitation
just give me the [__] butter put the
real butter in there I used to go to
movie theater in San Francisco that had
homemade chocolate chip cookies they
gave you milk with it
they also had popcorn and they melt a
stick of butter in your [__] popcorn
not a stick in your but but it would you
see the stick melting and real butter
yeah and you put salt and pepper on it
you dope it up you know this [__] now I
don't like going to movie theer and
eating
chocolate I'm at a different [__] age
you know what put together a [__] get
a [__] WWA to come in here and to
make little sandwiches back here be nice
sandwich
a bowl of lobster bis soup they got
chicken salad they got you know that's
the idea I would have in a movie theater
I want everybody comfortable these movie
theaters now it's not enjoyable anymore
it's not the people for me it's just not
I feel like I'm getting [__] ripped
out go and I have the AMC package my
wife got you know we have a family we
have kids you
know every time you go you're like give
us the disc
they still hit you with like $90 for two
things po I wouldn't need a pop I
wouldn't need a [__] my daughter gets
the popcorn if I do one they don't even
have raisin Nets anymore they have
limited [__] stuff in there now and
there STS but have you been to an have
to see if there's an Almo Draft House
near you I think that's what it's called
it's like one of those like fancy ones
like where they will have because I've
been to a couple there are places that
will bring you
food and it's [__] awesome so the
Alamo Draft House and they're not doing
comedy is really a movie theater right
yeah and it's like one of the nice ones
yeah that's right I've never been to one
I think they got one in DC and
uh you know somewhere else around here
who the [__] knows but
anyway where you going for Thanksgiving
brother I'm going to my my aunts and my
girlfriend's okay across the street and
then I'm going to be around the corner
so but I'm sure I'll talk to you like I
said if you can make it down here
tonight let me see what I can do I'll
call you this week and I'll let you know
what's going on uh me and a bunch of my
buddies are going out to dinner my wife
just told me that I don't the rest of
her games are in the daytime so I don't
have to worry I go out to dinner now the
rest of the [__] Saturdays I won't go
out this week because I want my leg to
heal but but anyway my brother Happy
Thanksgiving to you and your family and
hopefully before Christmas you will
absolutely thank you buddy and my man
Joe and the boys a little Happy
Thanksgiving to you [__] I know
you're in the back there
somewhere all right I didn't hear them
so all right stay
[Music]
bled freeze pipe listen freeze pipe
wants you to smoke and save big this
holiday season they're running their
biggest sale event of the year now
through the end of November but they got
some tremendous deals for Black Friday
perfect for medical patients who want a
cough free experience or anyone who's
tried who's tired of harsh smoke and
coughing and [__] spitting the secret
is a freezable glycerin Chambers just
pop the cham in the freezer for 1 hour
as the smoke passes through it chills
your throat you don't have no after bur
no coughing no nothing it's tremendous
they got listen the freeze pipe got
whatever pipe you need through small to
large to [__] Magnum bomb so try your
uncle Joey's favorite way to light up by
visiting thefree pipe.com again thee
pipe.com and anod Diaz D for 10% off
your entire order that's right shop
massive black Friday Cyber Monday sales
running now until the end of November or
use code Diaz for 10% off only at the
freeze pipe.com uh oh the checkin is
also brought to you by ho ho ho scumbags
Uncle Joey's here to put smooth balls on
your Christmas list manscapes new
performance 5 o Ultra has everything you
need to make your [__] Tree of Love
look awesome it comes with the LA Mo
Ultra body trimmer and the weed whacker
2.0 and an ear and nose hair trimmer
that crop Soo After Shave lotion which
is like putting ice ice cubes on your
nut sack and the crop preserver ball
deodorant this package is [__]
tremendous they sent to me about two
weeks ago I [__] trimmed it had
nothing to do that last week I was
horizontal so you might as well trim
your pole the lawn mow 5.0 Ultra does it
all it comes with two blade heads and
it's waterproof and it's even got a
light all right the performance package
is everything you need so you can shape
up look feel and your balls smell o p
get 20% off in free shipping with code
Joey at manscape.com again that's 20%
off and free ship
at
manscape.com use code Joey now if you
don't mind let's get this [__] party
started